seguin et bonsoir à vous bonsoir grosse
victoire effectivement vous avez quoi
réussir votre pari en fait de réunir à
nouveau le parti conservateur
oui on a gagné 55 % des votes le plus
grand nombre de votes jamais dans
l'histoire électorale de l'alberta sur
un mandat très profonde a pour créer la
croissance économique les emplois est
produite et pour une une situation juste
pour leur bataille à l'intérieur de la
fédération canadienne bon injustement
alors d'abord vous dites mon premier
défi pour la croissance économique
c'est de faire sortir davantage mon
pétrole de l'alberta
parlons de l'ouest d'abord la transe
mountain dans quelle mesure vous pensez
convainquent d'abord la
colombie-britannique d'accepter
finalement d'accroître le pipeline nous
allons commencer avec la diplomatie on
va chercher le les intérêts commune avec
les autres provinces
mais en bout de ligne nous serons très
clair que le nouveau gouvernement de
l'alberta est prête d'utiliser toutes
les outils légaux et politiques pro
défend défendre nos intérêts économiques
essentielles par exemple on est prêtes
de mettre en vigueur une loi qui a été
adoptée par les néo-démocrates opéra bon
pour permettre l'aberta et diminuer les
pétrole que nous versons aux clubs
britanniques ça aura oui ça augmentera
les prix du pétrole en colombie
britannique ça vous dire c'est un geste
que nous sommes sérieux
takao tg nos intérêts donc vous êtes
sérieux que vous pourriez fermer le
robinet pour la colombie-britannique
s'ils n'acceptent pas le transporteur
effectivement oui bon de l'autre côté si
le transporteur
ça prend du temps avez vous besoin
encore de pipelines vers l'est
donc il passerait par le québec nous
aimerions avoir plusieurs pipelines
parce que les canada le troisième plus
grand ressources de pétrole au monde et
maintenant nous perdrons dit
zen des milliards de dollars par année
parce que nous avons une seule manche et
internationale ça veut dire les états
unis c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
vendons notre pétrole à une prix une
sierre - que les américains ça nuit tous
les canadiens parce que coûte et
l'alberta a versé plus de 600 milliards
de dollars dont lé transfert de paris
qu'à sion aux autres régions y compris
le québec dans les dernières décennies
mais nous avons besoin d'une prix juste
pour qu'on puisse continuer à contribuer
au québec et le reste l'opération ou
qu'ici on aura pu avoir au moins dieu
pipeline pour les marchés internationaux
ça ça changerait tous le canada sera
bien placé à long terme avec la
prospérité avec du pipeline ok alors
pour qu'on se comprenne bien monsieur
calais même si 30 ce matin ça finit ça
fait ça fonctionne même si un jour ça va
fonctionner vous dites néanmoins
j'aurais besoin de l'autre pipeline qui
traverse serait entre autres l'ontario
le québec pourra les débouchés de
l'autre côté du pays pour exporter notre
pétrole alors que répondez vous à votre
nouveau collègue monsieur legault qui
dit y en a pas d'acceptabilité sociale
pour ce pipeline au québec mais il y a
j'espère d'avoir l'occasion à devoir
d'entretien à longueur avec monsieur
légaux que qui régirait je respecte je
respecte son accent sur la croissance
économique
son engagement à diminuer la dépendance
du québec sur les paires ication mais
cela étant dit il y a les pipelines les
oligarques qui fournissent le québec
avec l'énergie l'économie québec à
dépendent sur les pipelines y compris
les le pétrole qui viennent de l'alberta
actuellement tout ce que nous voulons
est de déplacer entièrement les
importations de pétrole des états unis
et des dictateurs de l'opecst avec une
augmentation de capacité à verser notre
notre pétrole au québec et au canada
atlantique alors il y à l'acceptabilité
pour le pétrole au québec actuellement
je crois qu'il ya plus d acceptabilité
pour le pétrole
duy au canada que celle produire aux
états unis et au l'opecst d'où vous donc
vous pensez que politiquement
monsieur legault pourrait s'il ne
voulait vendre ça aux québécois oui il y
à une sondage ça fait quelques semaines
qui indiquait que plus de 60 % des
québécois préféré à d'acheter de pétrole
canadien du west que le pétrole étranger
des états unis et de l'opecst je crois
que c'est une bonne marque que ya une
majorité de québécois qui qui veulent
appuyer leurs voisins canadiens qui
fournissent le québec avec beaucoup de
richesses dans des systèmes de
fabrication
allez-vous venir par exemple ici faire
une tournée on vous savez qu'un
élections fédérales qui viennent mais ce
chien vous aimeriez qu'ils remportent
j'en suis sûr allez-vous venir faire des
tournées et tenter de convaincre les
gens directement par tous pays
exactement je vais je faire exactement
ça c'est les raisons pour lesquelles
mardi soir dans le monde discours de
victoire
j'ai parlé français pendant plusieurs
minutes minutes pour envoyer un message
d'amitié et de respect qu québécois
parce qu'écouter il y à une alliance est
stratégique et historique entre
l'alberta et le québec tony zen et de 80
rené lévesque épidermoïde étaient les
alliés contre l'ingérence
constitutionnelle du pilleurs trou d'eau
j'aimerais avec françois légaux
renouvelle et cette alliance pour les
vieux province qui sommes bien placés
d'être les leaders dans la fédération
canadienne
est-ce que les albertains sont en colère
contre ses propos du pétrole sale encore
est-ce que ça ça a eu un effet négatif
oui il faut admettre je crois que
monsieur legault peut-être il
il va reconnaître qu'ils n'étaient pas
les bons choix des mots écoutez notre
énergie s'est produit selon les normes
environnementales et doite les personnes
le plus élevé au monde
je crois que les québécois comprend
contrainte qu'il préfère cette énergie
là à l'énergie
vraiment sale en point de vue environ
environ mon talent et doit être la
personne détecteur de l'opac c'est un
choix d'olten vraiment il faut faire il
faut prendre une chouette
vous avez dit monsieur qu'est née que
vous alliez organiser un référendum sur
la péréquation chez vous si jamais les
choses ne bougent pas assez vite pour
vous d'abord qu'un ce référendum et
quelles questions vous allez poser
etes-vous pour ou contre le principe de
la péréquation vous allez avoir 99 % de
vos citoyens qui vont dire qu'ils sont
contre oui et tu te fais écouter ce que
ce que j'ai dit et si nous n'avons pas
une pipe line pour accès au marché
international pour notre pétrole et si
le fédéral ne retire pas les projets de
loi comme ses 69 qui qui est une menace
à profonde à notre énergie et notre
industrie énergétique
nous aurons une référendum sur la
section delà de la constitution 36 qui
tout sur l'application en octobre 2021
écoutez je vais faire quoi avec le
résultat parce que les gens admettons
qu'ils sont archi contre la péréquation
sans doute c'est quoi la prochaine étape
le faire en vous donne sur la
souveraineté de l'alberta je suis
fédéraliste mais j'aimerais apprendre du
succès des leaders québécois qui ont qui
étaient tellement efficaces à défendre
les intérêts du québec dans la
fédération
et l'idée de cette référendum viennent
d'une décision du cour suprême sur la
référence de de sécession du québec
alors laisse cour suprême a dit à ce
moment-là que si une province à une
référendum sur une modification de la
constitution salon sera l'épreuve par
les négociations avec le fédéral ça
c'est l'idée c'est à élever nos des
membres de justice dans la fédération au
sommet de débats dans les fédérations
dont vous vous proposeriez en 2021 deux
roues
rires le dossier constitutionnel
pourquoi pas de régler la question du
québec puis des autochtones je veux dire
on voit le christ est devant nous
écoutez petit tiers des intérêts commune
sur les raisons pour lesquelles j'espère
qu'on puisse commencer avec une craie en
relation avec le gouvernement déco pour
défendre nos intérêts commune mais ce
qui est bien terminée beaucoup de gens
au québec ailleurs au canada s'inquiète
et monsieur trudeau va faire campagne
as-tu sur les gaz à effet de serre sur
l'augmentation
vous avez dit on va déplafonné on enlève
les taxes de carbone allons-y aux
produits il ya un réchaud vous admettez
que le réchauffement climatique n'est ce
pas oui je suis je prends très au
sérieux le défi à combattre les gaz à
effet de serre et sur les raisons pour
lesquelles notre plate forme qu'on
comprend un engagement pour une tarifs
sur les émissions industrielles qui
diminuera les émissions de 40 5
mégatonnes
oui mais si vous avez vos pipeline nous
à les produire davantage de pétrole il
davantage de gérer ça va de soi si le
canada ne fournissent pas les demandes
croit son internationale pour l'énergie
on va laisser ces marchés là haut à
l'arabie saoudite à la lironde enzo est
là et la russie je crois que c'est mieux
pour le monde mieux possibilité est
mieux pour l'environnement que le pays
avec les normes le plus rigoureux
fournissez marché croissant pour
l'énergie ok donc un terminant visite
parce qu'on est du pétrole profitons-en
au maximum puis envoie oui effectivement
pas lui mais plus mais dans le fond si
on ne fait pas d'autres vont lui faire
une place nous écouter il y aura dans
notre tarif sur les émissions une signe
en sont actifs pour les producteurs de
pétrole a continué à diminuer le full
carbon footprint leurs produits et je
suis écouté une des ses et des choses le
plus efficace que nous pouvons faire
comme canadien pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sera
d'exporter notre gaz naturel au marché
asiatique pour qu'ils puissent
à voir les économies beaucoup plus net
au plan environnemental
ça sera une période dans l'histoire d'un
petit canadienne fascinante qui commence
monsieur canet merci de cet entretien
c'est intéressant de pouvoir parler ou
six en français avec un premier de
l'alberta nous le saluerons monsieur ben
était désolé des morts français pernod
ils y croient bien non non non il est
très bien pire on gaze hâter le jour
d'élection que pour vous c'est important
de venir convaincre les gens partout au
pays et au québec on verra la suite des
choses
merci pour cette entrevue c'est moi qui
vous remercie